how has your life changed before and
after
you know i don't
to me it's like hard for me to see
other than like obviously my social
media following has increased but like
i'm not like i was never one to like
i guess like
i still feel the same like i'm still
doing the same thing i still go to the
same open mics i still hang out with the
same people
you know i'm not like flying around on
private jets i don't have like a million
dollars or more dudes sliding into your
dm 100 i guess what i got different oh
my god that reminds me dude she gets the
craziest [ __ ] dms dude the dms that
she gets everywhere
she's like everyone wants me to like put
your hot sauce in my butthole for some
reason like my butthole is just like a
huge topic of conversation in the dm you
want to put the hot sauce for your
butthole in your butthole they want they
they're they want it i don't know rachel
started
and a separate instagram account
strictly for the most hilarious dms she
receives and you just post them she she
posts them anonymously because she
respectfully blurs out like the handles
so she's not
why is it all about your butthole well
not all of them are actually i do get
some wholesome messages like i got this
message from this guy my mom sent to
prison years ago but he was like to be
fair he was like listen your mom gave me
so many chances i went through her court
i couldn't get sober but because of her
i got sober because he finally got his
life together it took like seven times
that wouldn't have made the wolfy dm it
did it because it did make the wolfy dms
because it was so outrageous that my mom
had you know sent this guy to prison and
here he is one saying so nice things
about her
and saying how much of a jackass fan he
was that one because i like to make i
don't want it to always be sexual
because like it's that's just like an
easy grab
i
and i think maybe i do remember that
yeah but so i mix it up some are i
throw some wholesome ones what's the
worst one you've gotten um
what's the what's the link so people can
go check it out it's wolfie dms
w-o-l-f-i-e
stevo's has been a supporter pretty much
since the beginning so i i thank you for
that um you know i just someone said i
no that one's inspirational um
you know
off giving you um gondola
people are like
um
uh
oh no okay this was bruh i would love to
lick whipped cream out of your beautiful
magnificent and exquisite booty hole i
don't know why they're obsessed with my
butthole
um and how do they know it's so
exquisite i know and someone somewhat
like people are really they're like i'd
let you ruin my life um oh oh if you
were my mom i'd still smash that was
[Laughter]
it's pretty epic yeah
um but yeah i mean
oh yeah just a lot of
a lot of really you know horrible good
great things in there i think that clip
was awesome but not as awesome as my new
book a hard kick in the nuts what i've
learned from a lifetime of terrible
decisions which is out september 27th
and if you pre-order it right now you
can get the autographed copy so
get on it man pre-order my book it's not
going to waste your time because i'm
proven dude new york times bestseller my
first book's five star rated on amazon
and i have no doubt this one will be too
so get the autographed copy right now
by pre-ordering it at stevo.com
yeah dude